der deutsche kommt
[Musik]
etwas gehabt und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich jetzt gut ich weiß
nicht ob alle von euch mein keine ahnung
kam irgendwann letzte woche in dem video
ging es um 1 und zerstörbare china handy
also die sind auf mich zugekommen mit
diesem gerät haben gesagt hier schicken
wir dir kann smart ist wenn die box
trägt demnächst auch ein anderes modell
zum testen und ja das ist halt ein handy
das ist extrem robust
es hat lange akkulaufzeiten mann soll
darauf gut games spielen können es ist
also ein gerät für alle leute die viel
unterwegs sind viel draußen sind auf der
baustelle arbeiten auf dem land arbeiten
was auch immer und ich habe mir im
letzten video vorgenommen hast du doch
mal wie robust oder stark das handy
wirklich ist falls ihr das video jetzt
noch nicht gesehen habt schaut euch das
erst mal vor diesem video an weil das
dann eigentlich ein bisschen cooler wir
sind auf jeden fall am ende mit einem
auto über das handy gefahren und
anscheinend hat er gehalten und kann
sich jetzt keine fortsetzung reden ich
würde sagen ich bin sehr gespannt ob das
klappt oh mein gott
ansonsten ist schön mit dir
aber check das ab zwei tonnen schweres
auto motor vorne also ungefähr 6 700
kilogramm gewicht auf der achse das hat
mir nichts ausgemacht und ich habe
überlegt was können wir noch tun wie
können wir das ganze steigern und ich
habe den termin bekommen und wir sind
heute zu besuch
also es ist noch dunkel draußen ich
drehe das ziemlich früh morgens und so
den termin habe ich nämlich um 9 uhr bei
action concept in köln
da werden coole action filme gedreht und
wir fahren heute mit einem ziemlich
schweren lkw rüber ich bin gespannt was
passieren wird um ehrlich zu sein glaube
ich nicht das ist stand falls es dennoch
weiterhin nicht kaputt geht habe ich
nochmal eine drohne dabei damit lagen
wir das mal hoch in den himmel und
lassen es von 500 metern da 300 metern
einfach mal auf dem boden klatschen song
contest gibt's nur bei mir deswegen
abonniert auf jeden fall den kanal ok
leute ich würde sagen wir laden gar
nicht lange fahren direkt mal los und ja
das nehmen wir mit
so leute wir sind jetzt hier bei action
concept in köln
die machen hier ganz viele
fernsehproduktion für irgendwelche
action serien oder so hier gibt es auch
ein hubschrauber und ich dachte dann
zeige ich euch mal kurz oder ich mein so
eine anmoderation dem hubschrauber wie
auch noch nie gemacht also es wirklich
sehr interessant hier stehen und selbst
viele autos ein paar lkws und das ist
eigentlich so die perfekte adresse für
mich um jetzt gleich das experiment mit
dem china handy zu machen also die
zweite runde praktisch eigentlich muss
man gar nicht mehr sagen ich meine das
handy habe ich alles schon gesehen
falls sich schaut euch den letzten teil
dazu noch mal an ist in der bibel
verlinkt und ja da bin ich mal gespannt
was da nicht drüber fährt der lkw soll
18 tonnen wiegen ich habe mich gerade
noch einmal informiert die achslast von
den dingen beträgt 7,1 tonnen
wir haben also praktisch das zehnfache
wie letztes mal bei dem auto ich würde
sagen kommt man mit
ich bin gespannt und mal sehen ob das
handy danach kommt ist also los geht's
also leute hier haben wir einmal die
lkws das ist der lkw der es gleichwohl
drüberfahren wird ich will jetzt kein
lkw experte oder lkw fahrer aber das
aber ich glaube größerer geht haben ist
auf jeden fall ziemlich hoch ich wollte
euch allerdings forderung war es zeigen
und zwar wenn wir jetzt schon mal hier
sind ich weiß nich kennt wahrscheinlich
cobra 11 die serie wird hier auf gerät
habe ich früher sehr gerne geschaut und
was ich wirklich so richtig traurig
finde hier stehen so geile autos und die
werden einfach zerstört ich meine schaut
euch das mal an die haben wir einen
mustern
also war zumindest mal ein v8 total
traurig oder hier der amg das war es das
ganz krankes ich war ja schon mal da
stand hier in hamburg gut auch einfach
zerstört es ist wirklich
[Musik]
so ist das halt wenn man diese
spektakulären bilder braucht regel jetzt
gleich zum lkw wir müssen auch auf den
fahrer warten und dann rollen wir über
das smartphone
bis gleich
[Musik]
leute ganz kurz doch es haben relativ
viele leute unter dem video geschrieben
also unter dem letzten hast das ja
nichts besonderes ist wenn ein handy
standhält wenn man halt im auto drüber
fährt und dass die neuen iphones und so
das auch können
ich habe das mal gegoogelt das ist
natürlich nicht so also wenn man über
einen iphone mit dem auto fährt ist es
schreit genauso über den neuesten
samsung was auch immer das habe ich
nicht so ganz geschickt deswegen bevor
sie wieder solche kommentare kommen
schaut euch doch mal so videos dazu an
da sieht man dass die kaputt gehen heute
also das ist der lkw überfahren wird das
handy ich auch immer schädlich gutes
wetter laut das ringen ungefähr zwölf
tonnen das heißt wenn wir eine aktien
sind aber noch sechs von der wir ganz
viele kommentare gelesen
das ist natürlich aufgeteilt wird und
das gewicht verlagern
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das
das doch auch das ist nach oben also
welche von plan rufen
oh okay das war's dann
ja
es geht doch gar nicht mehr als heute
jetzt aus
schade
stickstoff ist ich habe wirklich glaubt
das nicht kaputt geht aber irgendwie
kann sich auch denken
vorbei also hier ist immer noch nichts
passiert auf der rückseite der
bildschirm ist also komplett gesplittet
also das waren jetzt so um die sechs
tonnen die raubling herz das geil dass
er wirklich krass gewesen
dankeschön so leute herzlich willkommen
zurück
wundert euch wahrscheinlich warum sieht
das jetzt alles genauso aus wie als das
wie du angefangen hast ich habe alles
nachträglich aufgenommen aber hat
wahrscheinlich keiner von euch gecheckt
oder also eigentlich haben wir jetzt gab
schon so 20 uhr abends als wenn ich um
sechs uhr morgens aufsteht und diese
anmoderation dreh hat heute hier haben
wir das wunderschöne smartphone ja also
es ist wirklich zerstört komplett
zerstört und man sollte auch wirklich
aufpassen weiter fallen ein paar glas
bitte raus um ehrlich zu sein hat mich
das nicht verwundert man muss aber sagen
die unterseite ist eigentlich komplett
unbeschädigt geblieben ist auf diese
materie also ja also das problem bei
unserer meinung nach dass das handy
automatisch ein bisschen gekippt ist der
lkw dann drüber gefahren ist und dann
praktisch diese ganzen hat waren das
vorne sieben tonnen oder so da drauf
gedrückt haben genau das habe ich am
ende noch mal extra nachgefragt das war
ein 18 tonner also der lkw wiegt 18
tonnen und vorne irgendwie 14 tonnen
soweit ich weiß also es war wirklich
eine heftige kraft die draufgelegt hat
ich glaube egal wie man das hingelegt
hatte es wäre auf jeden fall
kaputtgegangen herz weiterhin
standgehalten hätte ich wirklich im
besen gefressen habe ich ja schon mal
sogar na ja auf jeden fall gehe ich von
denen bald noch ein weiteres handy das s
90 nennt sich das glaube ich das so noch
robuster sein wenn ihr sagt lass das mal
bitte aus 500 meter fallen jetzt mit
einer drohne in den himmel und das ist
dann halt fall gebt mir gerne den daumen
nach oben da ich auch mal spaß dran und
ansonsten mit diesem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie sonst
wahrscheinlich morgen also wieder und
danke nochmal alle die im video geholfen
haben und das war es von mir hier rein